今日はあの 法の観察の解説です
で 法の観察といって まあいろいろありましたけど
それからこの四聖諦や
その真理の方向へ心を向けて進み行かなければならないんですね
それで あのドゥッカについて説明しました
ドゥッカがわかってくると
ドゥッカのことをわかってくると
まあなんでこの五蘊というのは生まれてくるんですか？という問題が出てくるんですね
なんでドゥッカが生まれてくるんですか
ですから  2番目はドゥッカサムデで
苦しみはどのように現れるかという 2番目の真理ですね
カタマンチャ・ビックー・ドゥッカサムデヨ・アリーヤ・サッチャン
ヤーヤン・タンハー・ポーノー・バヴィカー・ナンディーラーガ・サハジャター
タトラ・タトラ・アビナンデニ
セイヤ・テータン・カーマ・タンハー・バヴァ・タンハー・ヴィバヴァ・タンハー
で まずこのドゥッカサムデ
ドゥッカが生まれる理由
あの 説明します カタマンチャ・ビックー・ドゥッカサムデヨ・アリーヤ・サッチャン
ドゥッカサムデという聖なる真理は何でしょうか？です
ヤーヤン・タンハー まあそのドゥッカがなぜ現れるかというと
それはこのタンハーですよと
渇愛ですよ このタンハー自体がポーノー・バヴィカー
タンハーの説明なんですけど
まあポーノー・バヴィカーというのはまあ生まれ変わることなんですけど
まあ再び存在を作るんですね
あの お釈迦様はこの生まれ変わりの場合は
パーリ語はプナル・パッティっていう言葉なんですけど
その言葉は使ってないんですね
生まれるということはウッパティって言うんですけど
この大体プナル・パッティという言葉は使ってないんです
使っている言葉はプナ・バヴァという言葉ですね
バヴァっていうのは まあ存在そのもののことなんですね
まあ個人がどこかで死んでどこかで生まれ変わるということではないんです
個人がどこかで死んでどこかで生まれるってことはプナル・パッティと言うんですけど
で プナ・バヴァという
プナ・バヴァという言葉を使っているんですね
バヴァっていうのはあるという意味でもありまして
存在ということでもあるし
まあ生き続くという意味でもあるしね
ですから このプナっていうのは再びまたということで
この渇愛の特色っていうのは
もうまたまたこの働きを作り続けていくんですね
ナンディー・ラーガ・サハジャター
この渇愛っていうのは
このナンディー・ラーガ
ナンディーっていうのは喜び
ラーガってのは欲なんですね
まあ喜んだりするんですね
喜びを感じたり 欲を出したりします
あの それからタトラ・タトラ・アビナンデニ
タトラ・タトラっていうのは
まああの 日本語は何でしょう
このここかしこで かしこでってどういう意味ですか？ かしこで
で まあその場でその場においてアビナンデニ
喜びを感じるという まあとにかく体の中でこの渇愛という
で 渇愛 まあ渇愛と言っても
このタンハーという言葉の意味っていうのは
まあただ渇だけなんですね
で 渇だけだったら次の説明はわかりますけど
渇愛といえば いわゆる渇っていうことは喉が渇いてる状態と同じことだから
まあ何か足らないというね
物足らないという感じが出てくるんですね
その何か足らないということがあるんだからこのその足らないものを探したり作ったりするわけですね
それがプナンパという言葉なんです
足りるんだったら探す必要はないんですね
だからその足りないっていうことが
人間のこの行動の まあ衝動なんですね
足りないっていう衝動で生命が生きているんですね
ですから 足りないという渇す状態が
乾く状態がプナンパが再生するんですね
で この乾く状態なければ再生はしません
で乾く状態あるんだからこそ
ナンディラゲサハガタそこで喜びっていうものが生まれてくるんですね
だから足らないものを得ると
なんとなくよかったっていう気持ちが生まれてくるし
それでまた足らない状態は消えませんだからまだ探したりするんですね
で そこでタッタルタットっていうのは
まあその場その場でっていうことで
だから探す探すものを見つけるたびに
そこでああ よかったよかったっていうことになって
そこで喜びを感じるようになるんです
それはこの乾く状態の特色なんですね
それで乾く状態は 3つに分けているんですね
セイエティダン それは何なのかと
1番目はカーマタンハ
で だからカーマタンハ
これ日本訳できませんし
カーマっていうのは欲で
タンハっていうのは渇いている状態
だからまあ カーマが欲しくなる
欲しくなるっていうことですね
まあカーマっていうのはもののことで
眼耳鼻舌身意 あのー 色受想
何でしたっけ？色受想行識
五属という 5つをね その 5つを探すということ
目にはいろんな見えるもの
美味しくなる 耳に音 美味しくなると
鼻に香りと で 体に感覚触れること
美味しくなるという 舌に味が美味しくなる
カーマっていうのはこの 5つなんですね
うん まあそれは一番わかりやすいことで
生きているものは何であろう
でもやっぱり体のこの感覚器官生まれる
ありますから その感覚器官に情報が欲しくなるんです
で  2番目はババタンハ
ババっていうのはまあ自分がいるということで
まあ存在ですね 死にたくないということなんですね
で 生きていきたいという気持ちで
まあそれはまあ心のことなんですね
だからあの眼耳鼻舌身をいじることはカーマタンハで
いじりたくなること ババタンハっていうのは
それ心の問題で まあ心の中でやっぱり生き続けたいという気持ちが生まれてくる
3番目はヴィバワタンハ
渇愛の 3番目はヴィバワタンハ
この生き続けたいということのもう反対なんですね
で その三つ あのカーマ
バヴィ バヴァっていうのは三つの渇く状態
で それまあ観察すると
心 自分の心っていうのはその三つでできているということを明確にわかると思いますけどね
心が常にこの あの 色声香味触という五つが常に希望して美味しくて探している
それからまああるという状態がすごく探している
だからまあ心の中で死にたくないという
生きてほしいという まあ自分の心の中にあるんですね
同時に まあ破壊的にも
あの 心が働くんですね
で 壊したいという風な感じ
だからその三つの働きで
あの できてるんですね
この渇いている状態が
だから一般の人には 普通の人にはなかなかまあそこら辺ははっきりどういうものかということはわからないんですけど
厳密に見ると誰にでもその三つはついてるっていうことは
まあついてます まあよくわかるのはこのカーマタンハですから
このカーマタンハにはものすごい執着がついてるんだから
バヴァタンハ ビバヴァタンハっていうのは隠れていてわからなくなっちゃうんですね
で カーマタンハからカーマから出たら
例えば出家したりとかね
もう瞑想したりすると
あの瞑想伸びかないのは
瞑想が進まないのはカーマタンハがある限りは瞑想は全然伸びてないんです
で 第一禅定も作れないんです
で カーマタンハを置いておけば
第一禅定でも作れますけど
そこからもうわかりやすくこのバヴァタンハが働くんですね
永遠にいたいと永遠を見つかりましたとかね
すごい我が強くなっちゃうんですね
だからこの軽々くでも瞑想した人っていうのは
結構我が強くて まあ高慢でっていう風になってきちゃって
そこで見えるのはこのバヴァタンハがすごく働いているということですね
それも置いておいちゃうと
そこでまあビバヴァタンハも隠れていたんだということは見えてくるんです
普段はあまりそんなにわかりにくいんです
最初は瞑想伸びてないのはカーマタンハ
それでいくら頑張ったところで
それでまだ止まったりする
それバヴァタンハだから
それもなくなっちゃうと
まあいくらかまだ瞑想っていうのは進んじゃいますけど
またそこで止まってしまっちゃうんですね
これビバヴァという破壊的な欲で
まあそこでまあ止まったりもします
で 普通の人々のことを見ると
もうたまたまあの この三つのひとつだけ派手に
あの パッとに機能している場合もありますね
例えば まあ欲だけ追っかけていく
あの 物だけ 物質だけを追っかけている人々はいるし
もうそれもうわかりやすくカーマタンハなんですね
いろんなもの ものばっかし
まあ見えるもの 聞こえるものとかね
もういろんなものを探したり
探したり で バヴァタンハの人々というのは
とにかくもう生きていきたいっていうことでも頑張っちゃうという
ビバヴァタンハの人も時々見えますけど
もう何でも壊しちゃうとかね
破壊する で 何でも壊して破壊して
もう過激的で もうすごい壊しちゃうんですね
まあ人々のこの考え方を見ると
例えば人々の書いてる本やらいろんなことを見ると
もう あの このどんなタンハが機能しているかっていうことはよくわかります
例えばこの金儲けの話ばっかりとかね
まあ綺麗な どんな風な建物
住処がよろしいですかとか
そういうあの本やらね
まあ哲学やら作ったりすると
そっち側に見えるのはカーマタンハ
物の世界だからね 今なんか大変人気あるという
あの絵本がありまして
何でしたっけ あの絵本は
葉っぱのフレディ  そう
あの犬の そう 四十万部も売れていると言ってますから
スヌーピーちゃうの？まあ日本人描いた
あの こんな名前 一匹ワンちゃん
あの小さい本で まああのまあ犬なんですけど
あの漫画みたいに まあ絵はすごい上手ですけどね
ちょっとまあ日本で 書いてる
で まあ犬と女の子なんですけど
まあ結局犬がこの 犬が喋ってるストーリーなんですね
まあだから絵はまあもしかするとまあ十枚に十枚しか入ってないんですけど
そこでストーリーできてますから
まあとにかく犬が一緒にいて欲しかったとかね
楽しかったとかね で なんでいなくなったんですか？っていう話で
それはまあ犬を飼っていた女の子がまあ死んじゃって
犬はそれわからなくて
なんでいなくなったと
何だろうかと どこに行くんですかと
また探したりすると それで目を閉じたら
まあ私が人のそばにいますよと
まあ死んだ人が言うと
そこ一緒にいるんだっていうことで
ストーリーはあります
で だからそちらにみんなこの読む人はもう誰でもあれを見てすごい感動するんだそうですけど
で そちらにあるのはこの存在
生きるということ まあ死んでも
まあ目を閉じたら そっちいつでも目の裏にいるんだという
で その欲を そこであれが悪い
これが悪い まあこういう調子では良くないとかね
いろんなこの批判的なことを書いたりする人々の中では見えるのはこういうバワタンハの方ですね
ですから まあそうやってこのいろいろ
タンハがいろいろな活動をしちゃうんですね
だからどちらにしたっても足らないということは
まあ基本的な働きで で
何か足らない だから破壊したくなるのも何か足らないんだからなんですね
まあこんな調子では良くないと
で ドッカをわかってくると
ドッカのことをわかってくると
なんでこの五蘊っていうのは生まれてくるんですか？という問題が出てくるんですね
なんでドッカが生まれてくるんですか？ですから 2
番目はドッカサムドゥーで
苦しみはどのように現れるかっていう 2番目
の真理ですね
カタマンチャ・ビッカラ・ウェ・ドゥッカ・サムダヨ・アリア・サッチャン・ヤーヤン・タンハー・ポーノ・バヴィカ・ナンディ・ラーガ・サハジャター・タトラ・
タトラ・アビ・ナンデミ・セイヤ・テーラ・タンハー・マ・タンハー・バヴァ・タンハー・ヴィバヴァ・タンハー
で まずこのドゥッカサムデ
ドゥッカが生まれる理由を説明します
カタマンチャ・ビッカラ・ウェ・ドゥッカ・サムダヨ・アリア・サッチャン
ドゥッカサムデという聖なる真理は何でしょうかと
ヤーヤン・タンハー まあそのドゥッカがなぜ現れるかというと
それはこのタンハーですよと
渇愛ですよ このタンハー自体がポーノ・バヴィカ
タンハーの説明なんですけど
まあポーノ・バヴィカっていうのは
まあ生まれ変わることなんですけど
まあ再び存在を作るんですね
あの お釈迦様はこの生まれ変わりの場合は
パーリ語はプナルパッティという言葉なんですけど
その言葉は使ってないんですね
生まれるということはウッパッティと言うんですけど
この大体プナルパッティという言葉は使ってないんです
使っている言葉はプナ・バヴァということですね
バヴァっていうのは まあ存在そのもののことなんですね
まあ個人がどこかで死んでどこかで生まれ変わるということではないんです
個人がどこかで死んでどこかで生まれるってことはプナルパッティと言うんですけど
で プナ・バヴァという
プナ・バヴァという言葉を使っているんです
バヴァっていうのは まああるという意味でもありまして
存在ということでもあるし
まあ生き続くという意味でもあるしね
ですから このプナっていうのは再びまたということですね
この渇愛の特色っていうのは
もうまたまたこの働きを作り続けていくんですね
ナンディ・ラーガ・サハジャター
この渇愛っていうのは
このナンディ・ラーガ
ナンディっていうのは喜び
ラーガっていうのは欲なんですね
まあ喜んだりするんですね
喜びを感じたり 欲を出したりします
あの それからタトラ・タトラ・アビ・ナンデミ
タトラ・タトラっていうのは
まああの 日本語は何でしょう
このここかしこで かしこでってどういう意味ですかね
かしこ  で まあその場でその場においてアビ・ナンデミ
喜びを感じるという まあとにかく体の中でこの渇愛という
で 渇愛 まあ渇愛と言ったっても
このタンハーという言葉の意味っていうのは
まあただ渇だけなんですね
で 渇だけだったら次の説明は分かりますけど
渇愛といえば いわゆる渇っていうことは喉が渇いてる状態と同じことだから
まあ何か足らないというね
物足らないという感じが出てくるんですね
その何か足らないということがあるんだから
この その足らないものを探したり作ったりするわけですね
それがこのタンハーというものなんですね
足りくんだったら探す必要はないんですね
だからこの足りないっていうことが人間のこの行動の
まあ衝動なんですね 足りないという衝動で生命が生きているんですね
ですから まあ足りないという渇状態が
渇く状態がプナ・バヴァ
再生するんですね で この渇く状態なければ再生はしません
で 渇く状態あるんだからこそ
ナンディ・ラーガ・サハジャター
そこで喜びっていうものが生まれてくるんですね
だから足らないものを得ると
なんとなく良かったっていう気持ちが生まれてくるし
それでまた足らない状態は消えませんだからまだ探したりするんですね
で そこで勝手だったっていうのは
まあその場その場でっていうことで
だから探す探すものを見つけるたびに
そこでああ よかったよかったっていうことになって
そこで喜びを感じるようになるんです
それはこの渇く状態の特色なんですね
それで渇く状態は三つに分けてるんですね
セイエティダン それは何なのかと
一番目はカーマタンハ
で だからカーマタンハ
これ日本語訳できませんし
カーマっていうのは欲で
タンハっていうのは渇いてる状態
だからまあ カーマが欲しくなる
欲しくなるっていうことですね
まあカーマっていうのはもののことで
眼耳鼻舌身に あの 色受想
何でしたっけ 色声香味触
という五つをね その五つを探すということ
目にはいろんな見えるもの
美味しくなる 耳に音が欲しくなると
鼻に香りと で 体に感覚触れること
美味しくなるという 舌に味が欲しくなる
カーマっていうのはその五つなんですね
うん まあそれはまあ一番わかりやすいことで
生きてるものは何であろうでもやっぱり体のこの感覚器官が生まれありますから
その感覚器官に情報を欲しくなるんです
で 二番目はババタンハ
ババっていうのは自分がいるということで
存在ですね 死にたくないっていうことなんですね
で 生きていきたいという気持ちで
まあそれはまあ心のことなんですね
だからあの 眼耳鼻舌身をいじることはカーマタンハで
いじりたくなること ババタンハっていうのは
それ心の問題で まあ心の中でやっぱり生き続けたいという気持ちが生まれる
三番目はビバワタンハ
かっさいの三番目はビバワタンハ
この生き続けたいっていうことのもう反対なんですね
で その三つ あのカーマ
ババっていうのは三つの渇く状態
で それまあ観察すると
心 自分の心っていうのはその三つでできているということを明確にわかると思いますけど
心が常にこの あの 色声香味触という五つが常に希望して美味しくて探している
それからまあ あるという状態がすごく探している
だからまあ心の中で死にたくないという
生きてほしいという まあ自分の心の中にあるんですね
同時に 破壊的にも あの
心が働くんですね で 壊したいという風な感じ
だからその三つの働きで
あの できてるんですね
この渇愛という状態が
だから一般の人には 普通の人にはなかなか
まあそこら辺ははっきりどういうものかということはわからないんですけど
厳密に見ると誰にでもその三つはついてるっていうことは
まあついてます まあよくわかるのはこのカーマタンハですから
このカーマタンハにはものすごい習慣ついてるんだから
バヴァ・タンハ ヴィバヴァ・タンハっていうのは隠れていてわからなくなっちゃうんですね
で カーマタンハからカーマから出たら
例えば出家したりとかね
もう瞑想したりすると
あの 瞑想うまくいかないのは
瞑想が進まないのは カーマタンハがある限りは瞑想は全然うまくいかないんです
で 第一禅定も作れないんです
で カーマタンハ置いておけば第一禅定でも作れますけど
そこからもうわかりやすくこのバヴァ・タンハが働くんです
いいみたいと いいもの見つかりましたとかね
すごい我が強くなっちゃうんですね
だからこの軽々くでも瞑想した人っていうのは
結構我が強くて まあ高慢でっていう風になってまっちゃう
そこで見えるのはこのバヴァ・タンハがすごく働いていることですね
それも置いておいちゃうと
そこでまあヴィバヴァ・タンハも隠れていたんだっていうことは見えてくる
普段はあまりそんなにわかりにくいんです
最初は瞑想がうまくいかないのはカーマタンハ
それでいくら頑張ったところで
それでまだ止まったりする
それバヴァ・タンハだから
それもなくなっちゃうと
まあいくらかまだ瞑想っていうのは進んじゃいますけど
またそこで止まってしまっちゃうんですね
このヴィバヴァという快適な欲で
そこで止まったりもします
で 普通の人々のことを見ると
もうたまたま あの この三つの一つだけ派手に
あの 活発に機能している場合もありますね
例えば まあ欲だけ追っかけていく
あの 物だけ 物質だけ追っかけてる人々はいるし
もうそれもうわかりやすくカーマタンハなんですね
いろんな物 物ばっかり
まあ見えるもの 聞こえるものとかね
もういろんなものを探したり探したり
で バヴァ・タンハの人々というのは
とにかくもう生きていきたいっていうことをでも頑張っちゃうという
ヴィバヴァ・タンハの人も時々見えますけど
もう何でも壊しちゃうとか破壊する
で 何でも壊して破壊して
もう過激的で もうすごい壊しちゃうんですね
人々のこの考え方を見ると
例えば人々の書いてる本やらいろんなことを見ると
もう あの このどんなタンハが機能しているかっていうことはよくわかります
例えば この金儲けの話ばっかりとかね
まあ綺麗な どんな風な建物
住処がよろしいですかとか
そういう あの 本やらね
まあ哲学やら作ったりすると
そちらに見えるのはもうカーマタンハ
物の世界だからね 今 あの
なんか大変人気あるという
あの 絵本がありまして
何でしたっけ あの絵本は
葉っぱのフレディ  そう
あの犬の  はい  四十万部も売れていると言ってますから
スヌーピー  まあ日本人書いた
うんと あの 何でしたっけ
あの女の子  百匹ワンちゃん
あの小さい本で まああの
まあ犬なんですけど あの漫画みたいに
絵はすごい上手ですけどね
ちょっとまあ一本日本で
書いてる で  犬と まあ女の子なんですけど
まあ結局犬が この まあ犬が喋ってるストーリーなんですね
まあだから絵は まあもしかするとまあ十枚に十枚しか入ってないんですけど
そこで一人できてますから
まあとにかく犬が一緒にいて欲しかったとかね
楽しかったとかね で なんでいなくなったんですか？っていう話で
それはまあ犬を飼っていた女の子がまあ死んじゃって
犬はそれわからなくて
なんでいなくなったと
何だろうと どこに行くんですかと
また探したりすると まあそれであの目を閉じたら
私が人のそばにいますよと
まあ死んだ人が言うと
そこ一緒にいるんだっていうことで
まあストーリーはあります
で だからそちらにみんなこの読み人はもう誰でもあれを見てすごい感動するんだそうですけど
で そちらにあるのはこの存在
生きるということ まあ死んでも
まあ目を閉じたらそっちでいつでも目の裏にいるんだという
で その欲を そこであれが悪い
これが悪い まあこういう調子では良くないとかね
まあいろんなこの批判的なことを書いたりする人々の中では見えるのはこういうバハヴァ・ダンハのですね
ですから まあそうやってこのいろいろ
ダンハがいろいろな稼ぐしちゃうんですね
だからどちらにしたっても足らないということは
まあ基本的な働きで何か足らない
だから破壊したくなるのも何か足らないんだからなんですね
まあこんな調子では良くないと
で 人を殺したり もう家を崩壊崩壊したりする場合でも
やっぱりもう何か足らないんだから
そうやって壊しちゃうんです
ですから 壊す時 破壊的な力が出ても
そちらでも自分が足らないことで大変乾いてるっていうことが基本的なんですね
乾いてるんだから足らないということで
で そこら辺は普通に瞑想する方が人にはね
まあ発見できる場合もできない場合もありますけど
すごい知恵が必要なんですね
これを発見するためには
で で それよりそれからの説明はもっとわかりやすいんです
瞑想するときは 次の説明は
サーコーパネーサービッキャウェータンナーカッタウッパジャマーナウッパジャティカッタニーサマーナーニウィサティ
ヤンローキーピヤルーパンサーサルーパンヨッテーサータンハーウッパジャマーナウッパジャティヨットニーサマーナーニウィサティ
サーコーパナエーサービッキャウェー
このタンナーという渇という乾くという状態が勝った
どこでウパッジャマーナウパッジェティ
どこで生まれます 生まれるんでしょうか
どこで現れますかと 生まれる場合は現れる場合はどこに現れますか？と
カッタニビサマーナ なくなる時はなくなる場合は
どこで亡くなりますか？その場所なんですね
だから場所で捕まるのは簡単ですから
そのどこで生まれますか？どこに消えます
どこで消えましたと 場所をチェックしてくださいと
ヤンローケピエルーパンサータルーパン
この世の中でピエルーパンサータルーパン
ピエルーパンっていうのはもう何でしたっけ
世界の愛しいって読んで恋しいですかね
世界の愛しい  愛しい  読んでよろしいのですかね
愛しいものですね 喜ばしいもの
ヤンローケピエルーパンサータルーパン
ヤン 何か世の中でピエルーパン愛しいものがあるならば
サータルーパン喜ばしいものがあるならば
エッテッサ そちらにタンナー渇く状態が生まれるんだと
ピエルーパンサータルーパン
ピエっていうのは自分の好みということで
サータルーパン サータっていうのは味わって良かったっていう
もうこの味わって良かったっていう意味なんですけど
まあ落ち着くと 気に入るっていうことも同じ意味なんですね
結局は  味わった満足感みたいなこと
で この世の中で何か愛しいものがあるんだったら
満足感を得られるものがあるならば
そちらにこの渇く状態が生まれるんだと
そこで じゃあ渇く状態がどこで消えてしまいますかというと
それもこの世の中で何か愛しい何かものがあるならば
満足できる何かあるならば
そこで消えるんだと 同じ場所なんです
だから渇愛が生まれるところで消えるんです
それはこのお釈迦様の思考といっても
この世の中の思考と違うところ
世の中の思考ではなぜ真理はわからないかということで
と なぜお釈迦様は自分が真理をわかったかというとね
そちらにもその差が見えてくるんですね
で 我々はこの体にいいものを食べたら体が健康的になる
体に悪いものを食べたら体の健康がなくなると
その場所が違うんですね
お釈迦様には体に体なぜ健康的ないいものを食べれば体が健康的になる
なぜ体が悪くなる 体にいいものを食べるんだから悪くなるんだ
同じ場所なんですね それは事実でしょうし
体にいいものを食べちゃうと体が壊れるんです
体が壊れることを維持したければ
何をすれば？やっぱり体にいいもの食べなくちゃいけないんです
だから体が作ることも壊れることも同じ原因なんです
音楽聴いて楽しいと思って
で そのそこで楽しくないっていうこともそこで生まれるんです
音楽を聴いて楽しい 違うものを聴いたら楽しくないっていう風にはならないんです
やってみたらわかりますからね
体にいい食べ物ばっかり食べてる人はずっと健康的で死なないんですか？ってそうでもないでしょうに
いくらいいもの食べたってもみんな同じなんですよ
もう同じく体が老化して取り損じて死んじゃいますからね
で なんでそうなるかというと
やっぱりこの原因は消えるんだからなんです
だから体にいい食べ物っていうものを食べたっても
その食べ物はもう消えるものだから
ずっとあるものではないんだから
で 何が体にいい影響を与えたっても
その影響は食べ物と一緒に消えてしまうんですね
ですから そこで消えるところでまた苦しみが生まれてくるんですね
そこで まず人間が大変愛しいものだと思うものは何でしょうか？と
チャックンローキーピエローパンサータルサン
目 目は我々にとっては大変愛しいものです
ですから 目の目に それからソウタン
耳ですね 耳は大変愛しいものなんですね
耳で渇愛が生まれる 耳で渇愛が消える
まだ消えないんじゃないですか
消えるのはもう一つ先じゃないですか
先ってどういう意味？ あ
あの えーと 言葉が出ませんけど
ニロ ニリッジャマナニリッジャキ
ここは  あ じゃあニリ  ここはニリサマナニリ
ああ そうなんですね だからニリサッティ
だから同じことですよ
ニリサマナっていうのはなくなるっていうことだから
あ そうですか  ああ ニリサッティとどまると訳せていますね
うーん ちょっと調べましょう
ああ ドッカニローデに別に入れてますからね
はい そうですね 今はサムデだけですからね
現れるだけですからね
現れる場所も消える場所も同じなんですけど
こちらの今説明したように
こちらに現れることだけなんですね
それはニミセティっていうのは違う意味で解きましたけど
こちらニミセティっていうのはこの住み着くという意味なんですね
いろいろ意味があるんだから
じゃあ続きます こちらにあるのはこの生まれるところ
説明だけ 消える説明は次のステップに入ります
第3の真理に入ります
で ガーナっていうのは鼻のことで
鼻っていうのは愛しいもので
そちらに渇愛が生まれる
で まあそれでそちらに渇愛が住み着くということで
ジウハっていうのは舌のことで
そちらに渇愛が生まれる
そちらに渇愛が住み着く
それからカーヨ 体ですね
体の中でまた渇く状態が生まれて
そちらに住み着いていると
それからマノ 心ですね
心の中でも渇く状態が生まれて
そちらに住み着いているんだと
で そこら辺は一応瞑想する時は分かりやすいところなんですね
目から渇愛が生まれる
耳から渇愛が生まれる
欲が生まれる 鼻で欲が生まれる
舌で欲が生まれる 体で欲が生まれる
それで頭の中で考えている時でも欲が生まれてくるんだ
だから欲がその体の感覚器官で生まれてくるんだっていうことが一応分かりやすい
で カーマタンハ ボータナ
ボータナを発見するよりは
そこら辺は発見しやすい
だから 一つだけでもタンハ見つかればいいんです
だからタンハ三種類ですけど
全部別々に見つからなくても
それは修行を進む過程においてどんどんどんどん発見していきますし
最初は何か分かりやすいカーマタンハを見つけたら
どこでこのカーマタンハが生まれるかというと
やっぱり眼耳鼻舌身意という六つ
六つのところで生まれるんだということがわかるんですね
体の中に生まれるんだと
で そこだけではなくて
さらに続けていくんですね
で 次のところでルーパローケ
ピヤルーパン サートルーパン
目は愛しいだけではなくて
目に入る対象も色もやっぱり愛しいものなんですね
それ愛しいものであるならば
そこに渇愛がまた生まれるんですね
なんで分けたんですかというと
例えばこれある人にとってはもう見えるものなくても見たくて見たくてたまらないと
いろんな綺麗なものを見たいという
もうたまらないと欲がある人もいるし
別に欲は機能していないんだけど
たまたま目に大変立派なもの目に入った
入ったところで欲が生まれたというケースもありますね
その二つのケースなんです
で 初めから欲があって見るものを探しに行く人がもいるし
別に渇愛が寝ているし
機能していないんだけど
たまたま目にすごいこと触れたところで
もう欲が生まれてきたという
突然欲が燃えてきたということもありますよ
だから その二つの働きで
人間の体の中で欲が現れて燃えていくんですね
だから個人では私はこのこれだけですよということはできない
決めることは で 例えば個人で自分の心の中でそんなに欲がないんですよと決めることもできませんし
で それはまあその時その時わからないんですね
基本的には たとえ綺麗なものを見ても
たとえ綺麗な声を聞いても
心の中で欲の種はなければ火が燃えてこないんですね
ですから 消す場合は体の中で欲を消すんであって
外の世界のことを消すということは仏教ではないんですけど
だから綺麗なものを見えたら自分に欲が生まれるんだから
世の中の綺麗なものを全部壊してやりましょうと
そうすると人に欲がないんだと言っても
それはもう無意味な方法で
生まれる場合は 主観的な態度からも生まれるし
客観的に外から入る情報からも欲が生まれてくるんです
そこで外の世界ではルーパ
見えるもの それからサッダ
音 それからガンダ 香り
それからラッサ 味 それからポッダッバ
触れるもの それからダンマ
心で考えるもの その六つがあると
また欲が生まれてきます
例えば 欲がない人にとっても考えて考えて渇愛を作ることもできます
そこが一番危険なことなんですけど
考える癖っていうのはなかなか治りません
だからいくら言っても治らないんですね
だからこの欲でも怒りでも無知でもできるように現れるように思考パターン付いてる人々は
いくら言ってもその方向へ考えてしまう
考えてしまって同じ原因まだ作ってしまうんですね
例えば 物事を考えて考えて悩む人がいるんだと
それでいろんなことを考えて悩むんだから
じゃあ仏教を勉強しようかと
思って仏教を勉強したら
仏教のことを考えて悩むんです
悩むこと消えません そういうことだから
それはどういうことかというと
この思考パターンなんですね
物事を暗く見る人がいるとする
そんなあんた 世の中を暗く見るんじゃないんだと
だから仏教でも勉強したらどうですって言ったら
それを仏教勉強して暗く考えるんです
そうやって思考のパターンもついてるんだから
なかなか治らない状態になっちゃうんですね
こちらで理解できるのはこのニッシューなんですね
で 初めから欲に燃えてきて
燃えている人 眼耳鼻舌身意の中で欲が燃えている人
それから外から色声香味触法に触れたところで
欲がまた燃え始めるという二つ
次のセットはこのヴィンヤーナなんですね
チャックヴィンヤーナ
ソータヴィンヤーナ ガーナヴィンヤーナ
ジウハーヴィンヤーナ
カーヤヴィンヤーナ マノーヴィンヤーナという
心なんですね 心も一つですよと言わないで
心というのは認識だから
目で認識する 耳で認識する
鼻で認識すると その認識は別々だと
目で認識して そこでまた渇愛が生まれてくるんだと
[紙をめくる音]で 眼耳鼻舌身意というところで
まあ眼識とかね まあ識です
うーん だからこの瞑想では
この別にこの渇愛見つかるんじゃなくて
この場所を見つかるんですね
だから渇愛そのものを見つかるよりは
この場所を見つかるのが簡単だから
だから目は場所を通してみたら
目で欲が生まれてくるんだ
渇き状態生まれてくるんだとわかってもよろしいし
目に触れるものをこちらから渇く状態生まれたんだっていう
そちらのその場所で発見してもよろしいし
あるいは目に何か触れたらチャックヴィンヤナが生まれてくるんで
眼識が生まれてくるんですね
じゃあ眼識がなければ渇愛がないでしょうと
見えなかったならば渇愛がないでしょう
見えたんだから欲が生まれたんだから
これは識の問題だといって識のところで見つかってもいいんですね
だから全部いっぺんに同時に生まれますけど
やっぱりどこでもいいんです
その場所は 目でもいいし
目に見える形で見つけてもよろしいし
あるいはあの眼識というこの心で
目で生まれた心で見えたということで
見えたっていうことで欲が生まれたんだ
だから見えることで欲が生まれるんだっていう風に見てもよろしいし
次の言葉はチャックサンパッサというパッサのことなんですね
これはどんな日本語訳ですかね
眼の接触から生じる感情は
触 あ 違うとこに 眼の接触は世界に愛し
いろんなところで触が出てくるんだから
ちょっと混乱するかもしれませんだけど
あの あの パーリ語では言葉違うんです
見つかるな 難しいな これ
三十四ページの最後の行じゃないですか
目の接触は ここね ね 接触と書いてますね
目の接触は世界に愛し
次の言葉は接触ですね
で サンパッサ まあ増えること
うーん そこで目の接触っていうのは
やっぱり目がずっと外の世界とコンタクトを取ってるんでしょうし
耳がずっと外の世界とコンタクトを取ってるでしょうし
鼻はずっと外の世界とコンタクトを取ってるんですね
だからこのコンタクトなんですね
サンパッサ 接触っていうのは
だからこの物があっても接触しないんだったら
またあの欲が生まれないはずなんですね
ですから じゃあ接触は問題だと
そこで欲が生まれるんだと理解しても構いませんね
だから接触も六種類ですね
眼耳鼻舌身意に六種類に分けているんです
次の出てくるのは このローマ字だったら九十ページなんですけど
二番目のパラグラフで
あのチャックサンパッサジャ ヴェーダナ ローケ ピヤ ルーパイン サーカールーパ
チャックサンパッサジャ ヴェーダナ
で そこは日本語訳はどうなってるんですか
接触から生じる感情  感情ですね
テキストはない で あの
接触から生まれるあの
感受性がありまして 感じるということ
それまた六種類に分けちゃうんですね
眼耳鼻舌身意に うーん
だから目で感じる 耳で感じると
この感じることで あの
欲が生まれてくる だから触れるっていうことはまた別で
まあ感じることはまた別々に分けてます
だから触れることは触れることで
感じることは感じることだから
機能としては違いますからね
触れるんだから感じるんですからね
触れても感じない時もあります
ですから感じることを別にしてしまうんです
で まあ例えばこの この絨毯見ると
絨毯の中で小さなホコリとかいっぱいあるかもしれません
で でも光はもっと小さいんだから
ちゃんと目には映してる
触れてるはずなんです
触れてるはずですけど
感じないんです 虫眼鏡でも使ったら感じるようになっちゃうんです
で 虫眼鏡で見るとホコリは見えるんであって
そうでないと見えない
で なぜかというと そこを見る虫眼鏡で見ると感じるんです
普通の目で見ると感じないんです
でも光はちゃんと届いて触れてるはずなんです
だから顕微鏡で見る微生物にしても
普通で見れば見えないでしょうに
でもそこからちゃんと光が届いているでしょ
目には 光届いてて触れてますけど
感じないんです だからそこから欲生まれてきません
そこで顕微鏡での下で見ちゃうと
感じ始めるんです そこで欲が生まれちゃうんです
ですから あの 接触から生まれる感覚
感受ということで欲が生まれるんだと理解しても構いませんし
次に出てくるのはルーパサンニャーローケピーローパンサータローパン
ロープサンニャー サンニャーっていう
で サンニャーっていうのは
まあですから あの  [背景音楽]
ルーパですよと 音ですよと
その概念作っちゃうんですね
まだまだ言葉になってないんだけど
一応言葉になる以前 概念が生まれちゃいますから
で 見た瞬間で まあその概念
そこで生まれちゃうんですね
その層っていうのはその概念のことで
まあルーパですよと だから見えたものはルーパですよと
形ですよではなくて 我々はなんとかの概念
虫ですよとかね トキビリですよとか
見つける 認識して見つけちゃう
見つけるまではいってないんだけど
まあその以前 もうすぐもう認識取ってるんですね
それはまあいつでも説明しているそうですからね
で ルーパサンニャ ルーパですよ
音ですよ 味ですよと一応わかってしまうんですね
だから感覚が生まれたら
あ ルーパでしたと あ 音でしたと
だから音が耳に触れた
触れるでしょうし 触れるんだけど
聞こえるはずがないんです
いろんな音が耳に触れるんだけど
ほとんどほとんど聞こえないんですね
そこで聞こえたっていうことは
もう感じたっていうことなんですね
感じたものは聞こえるんだからね
だから聞こえたという音という風にもう知ってるんですね
それはルーパ サッデサンニャ
で そういうことで また渇愛が生まれてくる
で ルーパサッデガンダラサポッタブヴィンニャーナというサンニャー６つありますね
サンニャーの次にこのチェータナーが生まれてくるんですね
このページの最後のパラグラフにチェータナーということが入ってるんですね
で 見たものをルーパというんですね
見たらそれについて何か気持ちが生まれてくるんですね
意志が チェータナーって日本語で何でしたっけ
思考能力 こっち  こっちは思惟と書いてますけどね
ページ 私に向けて だから話すんじゃない
思う時ね  これは意志ですね
気持ちですね まああの思惟というよりも
だから見たものについて
何か気持ちが生まれる
聞いたものについて何か気持ちが生まれてくる
その気持ちが生まれてこなきゃ欲がないんです
ですから このチェータナーの欲の原因という原因ではなくて
この場所ですね 場所を通して発見した方がいいと
サンチェータナーは決して思惟では訳しないんだけど
思惟と思うことだから
まあざっと日本語で読むと
まあ別に意味がわからないわけでもないんだけど
声に対する まあ思惟は世界の愛しい
なんで愛しい色 喜ばしい色と書いてますかね
訳自体はまあわかる 読んでないんだからね
で パーリ語で見れば 見れば
例えば ルーパサンチェータナーローキエピエローパンサータローパン
色であるというこの気持ち
色っていうのは見えるものであるというその気持ち自体がこの世の中で愛しいものであると
そこに渇愛が生まれて住み着いたと
それから音である あ これは音であるという気持ちが生まれてくる
で 香りである 味であると気持ちが生まれてくる
そこに渇愛が生まれてくる
次には言葉ダブっちゃうんですね
次にรูปタンハ あの 20 ページなんですけど
そこはパーリ語で見てください
รูปタンハローケピエローパンサータローパンエッテサータンハウパジャマナウパッジャティエッタニヴィサマナニヴィサティ
で そこでは本当にダブりますからね
で รูปタンハ รูปっていうのは見えるものでしょうし
見えるものに対してタンハ
渇く状態が生まれてということで
そこでタンハが生まれるんだというより
やっぱりダブってしまっちゃうんです
まあダブるんだけど なんでそういうふうに説明しているかというと
やっぱり場所で場所で場所で場所で探していったところで
その犯人が見つかるんですよ
目で 目で渇愛生まれるんだという場所を見つかる
見えるもので渇愛が生まれるんだというと
外の場所を見つかるでしょう
そこでコンタクトでしょうと
接触でしょうと 接触で生まれるんだと次の場所に移動するんですよ
あら ちょっと待てと 接触したっても感じなきゃ欲が生まれないでしょう
じゃあ感じることだと
目は目で感じる いわゆるヴィンヤーナ
眼識だよと 心なければ渇愛生まれないはずですよと
で ヴィンヤーナだけじゃなくて
次にこのサンチェータナ
サーンニャ  まあまあ とにかく接触が生まれる接触でしょうと
接触の次にヴェーダナー
感受性ですね まあ接触したっても感じたんだから
渇く状態生まれたんではないかと
そこで あの感覚が生まれたでしょ
これ目で感覚が生まれたことは問題だと
で 感覚の次にルーパサーンニャ
感覚からサーンニャが生まれる
そう思う概念 あ こういうものという見えたものに対して
ものすごい言葉一瞬のもう瞬時の世界なんです
だからこの見えた瞬間で何を見えたかともう知ってるんだから
あ そのサーンニャ そう
そうではないかと そうにしちゃうんですね
タンハの場所が で そうにした次に
ちょっと待て だってと
これ自分で見たいというね
意志があるでしょうに
で これ あの 想がチェータナから生まれるんだと
いつでも自分で知りたいという気持ちがあるんだから
この  チェータナというのは
あの  思い  まあ思うということで
意志 意志なんですけどね
とにかく目で見たいと意志がなければ見ないんですね
だから目は見たいんですよ
耳 目で見たいと意志がなければ見ないんですね
耳は聞きたいんですね
そのためにできている道具だから
だから あ やっぱりこの意志だよと
で 次にこれ どんどんこの見つけるのは難しい方へどんどん行っちゃうんですね
で 意志でタンハーが生まれるんだと思ったところで
最後に なんで意志って何なのかと
あ これは渇愛だと そこで最後に渇愛そのものが見つかっちゃうんですね
目の中 同じく耳の中でも
あ 渇愛そのものが見つかるんです
だからこの簡単な順番でどんどんどんどん厳密に本物を見つかるんですね
だから純粋な出来事だから
かなり瞑想しないとそれはできません
だから まず目にするか
確認作業を目にするか
見えるものにするか それをずっと長屋でやっていると
なんか感覚の方に心は感覚の方に行ってしまっちゃう
やっぱり目の感覚だよとかね
あるいは見たいと意志だよとかね
で見たいと意志に行ったところで
あ これで あ これがこの自体が欲ですよと
次に欲そのものが見つかって確認することができちゃうんですね
で それで この だからダブっちゃうんです
あの説明が この説明ダブるところで
やっぱり本当の渇愛そのものもラベリングできた状態なんです
で もう一つステップ進んでいくんですね
それはルーパー ウィタッコ
ローケ ピエ ルパン サータ
ルパンというところ で
ウィタッカっていうのは考えること
そこでですよ 我々言ってる概念があるのは
あ 花ですと あ 人ですと
見たものについて 我々知っている
あ 音ですと 音楽ですと
と思うところはウィタッカなんです
いわゆる考えることなんです
この見たのは何ですかと知る以前
この接触も 感受性も 想も
思も 渇愛ももう生まれているんですよ
とっくに先に だからこれは花ですよと知る瞬間で
もうとっくに渇愛が生まれているんです
その順番の速さ 考えたんだから欲が生まれたわけじゃないんです
あ これは花ですか なるほどと思ったところで
あ 欲が生まれたということはありえないんです
先に生まれている だから目を開けた
開けて何か見た瞬間でもう渇愛が生まれていて
それで何を見たかと 後で概念がついてくるんですね
これは花ですと それ概念後でついてくる
で この言葉がつくところはウィタッカなんです
ウィタッカは日本語何ですか
大まかな考察  まあ昔の言葉は仁なんですけど
まあウィタッカっていうのは
まあ言葉成り立つ状態なんですね
だから言葉を使う人には言葉が構成しますけど
言葉を使わない場合は概念構成するんですね
だから我々は全てのものに言葉を持ってるわけじゃないし
全ての音に言葉を持ってるわけじゃないし
で 言葉を持ってないんだから言って聞こえないわけないでしょ
言葉ないんだからって欲が生まれないわけじゃないでしょうに
だって分からない言葉で人が喋ったって怒ったりするでしょうに
うるさいと思ったりするでしょうに
ですから 何見ているかと分からなくても
それに添えて欲か怒りが生まれるでしょうに
だから言葉がなくても概念はできちゃうんです
言葉っていうのはそういうものが後で勉強して習うもので
言葉要りません だから人間がこの言葉を作ったんだから
コミュニケーションができなくなってしまったんですね
人間の間でも同じ動物なのにコミュニケーションできないんです
それはもう言葉 わざと作った人工的なものだからなんです
だからカラスの場合は
アメリカのカラスも日本のカラスも何のことなくコミュニケーションをとってます
なぜか言うと言葉作ってないんですね
それで随分会話できるんです
違う国で生まれた同じ同じ種類の動物だったら何のことなくうまくいってるでしょう
人間にだけそれできないんです
人間が言葉を使っているんだから
なんです だから言葉っていうのはもう後から出てくるもので
で この概念というのは言葉以前のものなんです
だから本当に哲学であろうが
心理であろうが何でも考えられますよ
言葉なしに 言葉なしに考える場合は
ものすごい強烈に早いんです
言葉で考えるとものすごく遅いんです
だからこの心を育てる場合は
第2戦場を作るとこの言葉を置いておくんです
荷物 だから心は伸びないんですね
言葉に引っかかっていると
これ人工的な作ったものだから
人工的な作ったものに引っかかっているんだから
心は伸びない 第1戦場まではなんとか作られますけど
第2戦場に心が成長したければ
言葉の次元を置いておかないと
ですから  第4戦場になった人には
もうありとあらゆる神通
超能力を身につけることはできるんです
とても簡単なんですね
例えば 人の心を理解したいと思ったら
別になんのことない カラス同士でもやってるんだから
人間同士でなんでやってできませんっていうのはありえないことなんですね
だから人間がこの人工的に作った言葉を置いておけば
もう何のことなく人を何考えてるかっていうことはわかるんです
言葉で喋ったらわからなくなっちゃうんです
だから これは別に難しいじゃないと私は難しくないと思いますけど
で 人が自分を感じたものを言葉で言ってますかね
同じ家族の中でも みんなお互いに喋って会話しているでしょうね
それ感じたものを言葉で言ってますかね
言ってないと思いますけど
だから言葉を通してなんとか推測したりするんだから
それでコミュニケーションのすごいギャップが生まれてきます
言葉なくなったらもう何のことなくコミュニケーション取ってます
だから結婚してる人々も
やっぱり老夫婦になったらかなりうまくいってるっていうことは
そういうわけなんです
全然喋れません ただ おじいさんがこっち側でおばあさんがあちらで
ただいるだけ あのいるだけでは本当の夫婦なんです
ものすごいお互いにお互いにコミュニケーションしているんです
でも喋ってはない おじいさんがちょっとでも調子が悪くなっちゃうと
まあ外で庭で何かいじってるおばあさんがちゃんと知っている
ちょっとしたことで知っている
物は置いた場所がちょっと変わっただけでも知ってます
今日はちょっと機嫌が良くないんだとか
若い時は口で言わなきゃわからないんです
同じご飯でも全部食べても
もう食べ方で 今日はちょっと味が気に入ってないんだと
今日の味は気に入ってるんだと
でわかるようになっちゃうんです
それってことは もうほとんどもう会話がないんです
言葉の会話が それはもう言葉に依存してる世界では良くないと思ってますけど
別に自然の世界から見ると別にどうったことないんですよ
動物同士でも死ぬまで夫婦がものすごい真剣に頑張ってる動物もいるでしょうね
一言も喋れません でも死ぬまで動物の夫婦だったらね
動物の種類によって違いますけどね
やっぱり一夫一妻制というんですか
そういう動物いくらでもいるでしょうに
相手が死んじゃったら死ぬまで自分が一人でいるという
鳥とかいますからね で
長生きする時でも 全然お互いに別に喋るということをしません
これ喋る場合は あれは喋ってるんじゃないんです
あれはあのある特別な違う行動だけなんです
言葉で喋ってるわけじゃないんです
そういうことだから こちらのこの最後のセットに vitakka という言葉使って考えることを入れているんです
vitakka っていうのは言葉使ってもう考えること
ですから 例えばあの花見ただけでもしかするともうかすかな欲しか生まれてなかったかもしれません
でもそこで言葉で考えたりすると
この色はこういうものだと
この種類はこういうものですよとかね
これはこういう風に育てたものですよとかね
あるいは過去の何か経験を持ってきて
この花はもう自分の田舎でよくもう咲いていましたよとかね
思ったりすると もうどんどん欲がまた生まれていく
渇愛が生まれていく ですから
この vitakka で
なんでこの渇愛の真犯人見つかったのに
もう後から vitakka 入れたんでしょうかね
vicāra も  vicāra も入ってますけど
vitakka  vicāra セットだからね
で これパーリ語の注釈書の解釈すごいわかりにくいんですけど
vitakka 尋思というふうな言葉で漢訳もしていますけど
vitakka は粗っぽい思考で
vicāra はきめ細かな思考っていう
細かな考察って書いてある
という個別性なんですね
だから一般的には誰にでもまず vitakka が生まれてきて
それから厳密に細かに物事を考えるということ
大体 2つ一生なんですね
行動する場合は だから説明するときは
この 2つも一緒にした方がやりやすいと思いますけど
考えることからまたいろんな欲が生まっていく
何を考えるかというと
目から触れた情報について考える
耳から触れた情報について考える
舌から入った情報について考えるということだと
頭の中でもすごい考察の機能が工場みたいな感じで
すごい勢いで働いているんですね
ですから かなり強烈に欲が生まれてくるんですね
だから欲が発見 一番発展しやすいところはその思考の世界なんです
なんでそんなにも欲があって
なかなか何で消えないかというと
考えてるんだからな 人間が言葉でもって考えている
他の言葉を使わない人々は言葉がなくて概念の並び替えで考えている
だから言葉なくても考えてるんです
人間よくやってますよ
言葉なしに考えるっていうことは
ずっと言葉でやってるわけじゃないんです
言葉でやってるのはほんの一部だけなんです
ちょっとヴィパッサナーで観察してみれば
もういとも簡単に発見できます
発見できます 言葉でやって考えないで
なんとなく もうこんなんて言いますか
反射的というか なんでいろんなことを稽古するんですかね
それいろんな稽古をするのは言葉なしにやるためなんです
音楽を楽器弾きたければ
もうちゃんと楽譜を書いて
このノートはこういうふうに押すんだとかね
で 書いて書いて読んで
これはどうだからこうやってどうで
次はハーフトーンでこれとかできません
考えてるんだから それで練習するんですね
練習すると 楽譜見ると指がちゃんと言ってるんです
見ただけでこのメロディが頭でパッと浮かんじゃうんです
楽譜を見た瞬間ですぐもう浮かんでるんです
音が 言葉出てきていない
それでいきなり楽器弾ける
で それには何年間も毎日毎日長い間訓練しなきゃいけない
この訓練をすることによって
この言葉のこの邪魔者を
障害をカットするんですよ
この訓練っていうのはそういうことなんです
いろんなことを訓練する場合は
どんな世界でもこの言葉の世界をカットするんです
車を運転習う時でも同じことなんです
だから ちょっとしたマニュアルだけ持っていれば
車の運転の仕方では全部書けるでしょうに
交通の法則やら信号の理解やら
これも取っていても簡単にわかるでしょうに
だから言葉でわかる分だったら私も知ってますから
車運転はどのようにすればいいかどうかね
道路に出る時はどのようにすればいいかどうかとか
信号でどういう風にしますかと
これは駐車禁止やと これは一方通行だと
こちらはベンドですよとかね
カーブですよとか それぐらいのこと自分も全部知ってます
もし試験だけだったら私ももう合格しますよ
すると思いますよ でもそれ全て言葉の世界で
実際の運転はまるっきりできない
私も運転 ちゃんと公証場に行かなくちゃいけないんです
そこで怒られるながら
叱られながら またいろいろ失敗しながら
もうやってやってると
どんどん言葉の台を置いておくんです
で 言葉が消えたところで運転ができるようになる
だから全てのものはそういうことなんです
だから上手な人っていうのは言葉使ってないんです
はい  そういうことだから
この人間 人間も まあうまくやると場合
うまく何かする場合は言葉使ってないはずなんです
どんなどんな機械を動かす時でも
料理作ってる時でも まあ料理は初めて作る場合は
何かある料理を初めて作る場合は
テキストを開けて これは大さじ 1杯か 2杯か
小さじ半分か もういろいろ見ながら見ながら
もう何グラム入れますかとかね
もうテキスト見ながら苦労しなくちゃいけない
その場合は全部言葉の世界でかなり遅い結果もちょっと信頼できないと
ちゃんと身についちゃったら
言葉何もないし 他のことを喋りながらササッとその料理を作ることができるようになっちゃうでしょうね
言葉使ってない だからこちらは正しい順番で書いてあって
目で渇愛が生まれるんだとまず確認されてて
それから見えるもので渇愛が生まれるんだと確認して
それからヴィンヤーナで渇愛が生まれるんだと確認して
それからコンタクト接触で渇愛が生まれると確認して
それから感覚で生まれると確認して
それから意思で確認が生まれると確認したりして
それから あ 渇愛やと 渇愛そのものを確認するようになってきて
それで終わっちゃいますけど
次にやっぱり人間っていうのはどうにもならないように
もう渇愛が生まれて燃えてくるっていうことを
この概念の並び替えの問題であるということで
一番わかりやすいところで終わってるんですね
でもヴィタッカヴィチャーラ
人身なくても渇愛が生まれるんだから
それを先に入れたんです
人身だけで渇愛が生まれるんだからと言ったら
だったら虫とかね 渇愛あるかないかちょっと疑問になっちゃうんですよ
ただ生きてるだけだから
でも認識しちゃうと そこにも渇愛が生まれているんです
認識機能あるんだったら
虫にも認識機能あるんだから
アメーバにもありますから
それで渇愛が生まれるんです
で それより一番渇愛に悩んだり困ったりしているのは
この概念で 人身でもう苦労している人々ですね
かなり強烈に出てきて
機能している その同じ原因で渇愛を足すことも
そういう人々にできるんですよ
そのように渇愛が生まれるんだと理解していけば
だから法の観察はまあ結構難しいんですけどね
で それよりこちらで一般的に仏教の知識として理解してほしいのは
やっぱりこの苦しみの原因というのは体にあるものだと
すごい合理的なんですね
具体的なんですね 神にあるんじゃないんだと
得体知らないどこかに外にあるんじゃなくて
体にあるんだと 外も捕まっていますけど
色声香味触法と言えば
それでも体に触れてる周りの世界だから
外の世界にいたっても
自分の体に触れてる世界でしょうに
我々は別に 例えば北極でもう寒くて苦しいんだという
別に関係ないでしょうに
触れてないんだから そちらはもう半年間もう暗闇で
もう太陽が出てこなくて
半年間も一個きつくて
もう嫌ですよということは一個に関係ないでしょ
だから天国のことも我々にとっては一個に関係ないものなんですね
だから外の世界っていうのは体に触れる世界なんです
体に触れないことは別に関係ないんだと
だからこの体の中だけ
もうすごくジュワジュワと渇愛が生まれてくるんだという
もう簡単単純に理解できるところなんです
で  二十七書いてるところから
この渇愛の消える方に行きます
そこでカタマンチャ ビッケ
ウェー ドッカニロード
で 瞑想する人は次に考えてほしいのは
この苦しみがどのように消えるでしょうかと
それでまた単純な答えで
渇愛から苦しみが生まれるならば
渇愛がなければ苦しみがないでしょうと
この渇いている状態さえなければ苦しみがないでしょうと
ですから ヨータッサーエーバタンハヤ
その渇いているというタンナーそのもののアセーサヴィラーガニロード
アセーサ残りなく離れて滅すること
いわゆるきれいさっぱりこの渇き状態消しましょうと
チャーゴーパティニッサーゴー全部離れることなんですね
ムッティアナーラヨ ものすごい動詞を使ってるんです
こっちアナーヨとありますけど
アナーラヨなんです エルエー落ちてるんです
ヨータッサーエーバタンハヤアセーサヴィラーガニロードチャーゴーパティニッサーゴームッティアナーラヨ
そこでこのパーリ語ではこのアセーサヴィラーガ
アセーサっていうのは残りなく
ヴィラーガ離れること
ニロダっていうのは滅すること
同じ意味 チャーゴーっていうのは捨てること
パティニッサーゴーっていうのはそれまた捨てるっていう意味で
ムッティっていうのは離れるという
脱出すると アナーラヨっていうのは喜ばない
そこは私の世界ではないと
自分アイデンティティ化しないこと
だから結局同じ意味ですよ
もう完全にきれいさっぱりこの渇く状態から離れましょうと
そうすると苦しみが消えるんだと
そこでまたこの文章は全く同じ
ほんのちょっと変わるだけ
次に同じこと サーコーパネーサービッケタンナカッタパヒーエマーナパヒーヤティ
どこで消えていくんですかとか
カッタニルッジャマーナニルッジャティ
どこで滅していくんですかと
場所を探すんですね ヤンローケピエルーパンサットルーパンエッテサータンハパヒーエマーナパヒーヤティエッテサータンハニルッジャマーナニルッジャティ
ニルッジェもしこの世の中で愛しいものが何かあるならば
そこでタンハーが消えていくんだ
そこで滅していくんだ
同じ場所なんです 現れる場所も消える場所も現れるところで消えるんだった
こういう風に書いているのは
これも暗記しやすくするためなんです
これは瞑想だから 厳密にもうものすごく厳密に暗記していかないとやりにくいんです
ですから これをものすごい暗記しやすい
大体二 三回読むと暗記できるんです
それで言葉も並び替えも発音しやすくして並び替えてずっと書いてる
だから同じことを二回出てくると
文字で読むとなんか面倒くさいなって感じるかもしれませんが
文字で読まないで耳で聞くと全然そうは感じません
すごい耳障りがいいんです
そういう録音したテープもいろいろありますけど
こちらではないんだけど
すごく何回聴いても心にものすごく喜びが生まれてくる
それぐらい耳触りがよく綺麗にこういう言葉できてるんです
どこでなぜ気持ちを聞こえるかというと
ちょっと聞いただけで自分にも一緒に言えるんですね
だから瞬時にこの聞いた人は乗ってしまうのです
ただ それぐらいこのこれはもうインパクト強く
この渇愛の生まれる場所と場所を見つける方法
その順番を頭に記録しておかないと
そこがこの悟りの世界
ここから生まれるんだから
今までの瞑想っていうのをコソコソ速度でいいんです
体の瞑想とかね それは全部やらなくたってもよろしいし
ここは法の観察になってくると一番大事なのはこの死生帯発見することなんで
死生帯を発見してきた人だけ覚るんだから
その中でも渇愛の機能はちゃんと発見しないと覚るということはありえないんですね
だからそこら辺はすごく耳障り良く覚えやすく
凄い丁寧に順番で繰り返して繰り返して繰り返していていってるんです
カッタ・ニルッジャ 「
ヤンローケピエルーパンサータ・ルーパーンエッテサターンナーパヒイェマーナーパヒイェティエッターニルージャマーナーニルッジャ」まあ喜ぶ愛しいところ
世の中に愛しいものを好みのものという所で喝采が消えていくのだと
それで説明は前とまるっきり同じ
ただ無くなるんだ なくなるんだという言葉入れ替えるだけなんですね 「
キン
チェローケピエ・ルーパンサータ・ルーパーンチャッカ・ローケピエ・ルーランサータ・ルーパームンテサートンアーナ―パヒーエマナナーパヒーエティエットゥニルジョ
マナ ニルジョ ティートォトン ローケ ピエ ループ サン サール パン エッテ さあ
tan На パヒーエ 마나 파희 에티エットゥ
ニル ジョマ ナニ ロッジョ ティ」 「ソーたんローケぴえループ さんさぁテループ さん ఎ捨て satan
なぱひぃへまなぱひィเอtiエッとニルッジェマナニルッジょてぃ」「ガーナンローケぴえループ さんさアテループ
さんエッテさてアンナーパーヒーエマーナーパーヒーエティエットゥニルッジェマーナニルッヂェティジーヴァーローケぴえルー
プ さんさァテループ さんエッテさてアンナーパーヒーエマーナーパーヒーエティエッとニルッジェマーナニルッヂェティカーヨーローケぴえループ
さんさァテループ さんエッテさてアンナーパーヒーエマーナーパーヒーエティエッとニルッジェマーナニルッヂェティモノウローケぴえルー
プ さんさァテループ さんエッテさてアンナーパーヒーエマーナーパーヒーエティエッとニルッジェマーナニルッヂェティ
」 ということで 最初にこのチャックスオーターガムディバーカーマン眼耳鼻舌身意というところで消えていくんだと
それから色声香味触法というところで渇爱消えているんだと
ここがか対象かどちらで消えていくんだろう
そこにチャックウィンヤーナやっぱり眼耳鼻顔色眉識とかね
そういう感覚機能があるんだから
渇爱が生まれるのではないかと
目があるんだから渇爱が生まれるわけじゃないんだろう
目には目の感覚はあるんだからでしょうとヴィンヤーナにいっちゃうでしょうに
そこで感覚あっただけで渇爱は生まれません
これ接触だから いや 接触があっただけで生まれるわけじゃないんだと
これ感じちゃったんだから
感受性だから渇爱が生まれたんだと
消えるのもそこで消えるんだと
だって感じただけではないんだと
で ルーパサンニャー だからこれをこういうものやこういうものやと自分の層
これを受け取っちゃったんだから
それは本当は私が概念とするかっていうのはそこなんで
普通の世の中で概念というのはヴィタッカなんで
言葉の世界なんです 私は概念と呼ぶのはここら辺で
この感じた瞬間で生まれるものが概念なんです
そういうところで消えていくんだと
そこでルーパタンハと言って
最後にルーパヴィタッカ
それからルーパヴィチャーラ
ヴィタッカヴィチャーラまで同じ場所でもタンハー渇愛が消えていくんだと
で なんで違う原因が入り込んで消さないんですかと
だから俗世間の考え方を見れば
違う原因が入ってきて
それ消さなくちゃいけないんですよ
仏教ではそうじゃないんです
目で渇愛が生まれると同時に目で渇愛が消えると
だからそこで消さなくちゃいけないんですね
サティで消す  ん？ サティで消す
うーん 消すというよりも
やっぱり消す場所なんですね
あのー  消えてくれるのはサティ
サティとはちょっと言いにくいんだけど
サティっていうのは実践方法だから
うーん この働きがわかることで
発見することで智慧と同時に消えるもんですから
だから智慧というのは特別なものではなくて
このもう働きはありのまま見られるということで
うーん まあこれそれはちょっと答えにくいもんなんですね
車運転上手になるためにどうすればいいんですかね
車運転するしかないでしょうに
で なぜ車運転上手じゃないかと聞くと
それは概念が考えてるんだからなんです
事故 事故ったらどうしようかと
まあ信号ですよとかね
考えちゃうと運転できないんですね
だから運転下手な人々っていうのは
よく考えるんですね 上手になるために
もう考えない方がいいと言ったっても
まあそれはそうなんですけど
じゃあどうすればいいかと
まあ運転してみるしかないんです
だからまあそんな風な働きで
まあこの機能をその通りに見てみるということで
もう機能はわかってきますし
それでまあ消えちゃうんです
だから消える方法っていうのは
テキストになければ言う必要はないんだから
で 最初に出たと思いますけど
これ ずっと高校のテキストでこの生まれる
消える 生まれる 消えるというこの 2つで成り立ってるでしょ
現象っていうのは何だかんだでも
ジャーティとニローダ
ウッパ―ダ ニロッドという 2つで生と滅で物事は成り立っているでしょうに
だから生次に滅 次に生
次に滅 だから生の次に滅はあって
滅の次に生があるという順番なんですね
すべての物事に だからチャック
目があると言ったら 次に目が滅状態でしょうに
ルーパの場合もそこも生滅の流れでしょうに
だから生じると渇愛が生まれて
滅せちゃうとその渇愛も消えてしまうんですよ
だからどこに消えるかというと
そちらに消えちゃうんですよ
目で生まれた渇愛が耳で消えるわけじゃないんです
場所を移動できません
それはこの生滅論なんです
いわゆる無常なんですよ
だから ものすごい勢いで
物事もそうそう接する勢いで変化していくんですね
だから このそうそう接する勢いで変化していくんだということに目覚めたら
そこでもう二度と煩悩が生まれなくなっちゃうんですね
だからそこに邪魔してくるのは我々の概念で実体論なんですね
ものはあるんだという概念が渇愛作ってるんですね
だから作って作って この滅ということは見ないんですね
だから滅見られると渇愛が消えちゃうんです
これはまあ同じ 自分にはすっごく気持ちのいい音楽がありますとする
その音楽はずっと聴いてるとずっと気持ちいいんでした
すごい気持ちいい音楽ある場合は聴いたらすごく気持ちよかったです
そこでものすごいずっと 1 日中聴いている
そうするとどうなるんですか？なぜ嫌になるんですかね
自分がものすごい食べたいものがあると
それを食べまくっちゃうと
朝も昼も夜も間食もすべてこの好きなものだけ食べてみるとどうなるんですかね
すごく嫌になるでしょ
他の方で他の食べ物を食べなさいと言って入れ替えたっても
欲を消すことはできません
で 私たちはやっぱり 何か好きなものがずっと隙間なく
その好きなことをやっちゃうとすっごく嫌になって拒絶反応を起こしちゃうんです
なぜそうなるかというと
それはすべて無常だからなんです
とにかく だから同じものはないということなんです
同じ音楽はないんです
同じ耳がないんです 違うもの
違うもの生まれていくんですね
違うもの生まれていくんだから
どんどんどんどん あら違うと
例えば朝 6時で音楽を聴き始めて
午後 6時になっちゃうと
違うんですよ もう嫌なんです
もううるさいんです 聴きたくもない
もう一生聴きたくはないってことになってるかもしれません
それぐらい耳も音も変化しているんです
だから人間が苦しみだというのは
この滅することは嫌がるんだからなんです
滅することは嫌がるのは
ろくに見てないんだからなんです
ろくに感じてないんだからなんです
だから鋭く観察しちゃうと
問題は解決するんだと
ろくに見てないんだからあるんだと勘違いする
あるんだからと思って欲がずっと続けていっちゃうんですね
じっと見ちゃうと あるんじゃなくてあって消えちゃったんだと
どうったことはないんだっていうことになるんです
それも観察能力をあまりにも鈍いんだから欲が生まれてるんですね
だからもうとにかく観察能力をもう徹底的に育てることは必要です
徹底的に育てると無常に気づくんですね
無常であることは気づいちゃったら
もう何もないんだっていうことをわかっちゃうんですね
何もないんだとわかったところで欲が生まれてこないんです
何もないところで そういうことなんです
欲が消えるっていうことは
無常に関わるもので アニッチヤ
ドゥッカ アナッタ 無常
苦 無我という三元色を発見すると欲がなくなっちゃうんです
三元色を発見するために
この四聖諦の瞑想をしなくちゃいけないんです
無常の法の説明はどこかで
それはどこか特別なところに入れてないんですよ
いつでも無常で説明しているんだから
この前の法の観察の中でも
現れること 消えること
両方言っていましたから
今の場合も現れること
消えること 両方言ってるんだから
だから無常はずっと言ってるんですね
ずっと言ってるんですけど
それに気づくと消えるんですね
だからそれに気づくと消えるっていうことは
またちょっと言葉はおかしいんだけど
渇愛はすべていつでも消えていくんですよ
消えたらまた生まれるんですね
消えたらまた生まれる
その流れが問題であって
無常に気づいた人が一旦消えたら
また二度とそこは渇愛はそこらない
それだけの差なんです
だから無常はずっとあるんだからね
だから無常を発見していないと
さらに欲する さらに欲する
さらに欲するということに行っちゃうんですね
なぜさらに欲したくなるんですか？って過去の欲が消えちゃったんだからでしょうに
なんですっと渇く状態ありますかというと
一旦渇く状態あったとする
それで欲しがる 欲しがったものは得たとする
それで渇く状態は消えるはずでしょうに
でも渇く状態は消えないでしょ
渇く状態はまた続くんだから
なぜ続くかというと 得たものは消えちゃったんです
同時に渇く状態も消えちゃって
違う渇く状態生まれたんですね
だから違う渇く状態に違うものを必要になっちゃうんですね
そうやって延々と無限に渇く状態も変わっちゃうし
欲しがるものも変わっちゃうし
だからこの生と滅の流れで無限に繋げていっちゃうんですね
だからこれは無常であると
キリがないんだと ということに気づくんですね
だから どんな説明の中でも
お釈迦様は無常に無常自体発見できるように説明しているんです
そこを発見すれば このこの流れが止まってしまっちゃうんです
無常ということ じゃあ一応ドゥッカサムデヴァはこれぐらいにしましょう
その時間が延びましたし
ドゥッカニロダで終わりますけど
この瞑想は  [終始背景音楽]